I think it was a sort of major
achievement for eunuchs actually that
you know it's its big claim to fame is
yes we Dennison can we wrote the UNIX
kernel in C we had to have a few dozen
lines of assembler and maybe somewhere
in there there's the odd sprinkling of
go twos and there's good excuses for it
sometimes in the heart of an operating
system but they're even they're
massively reduced from what they would
have been so that was the whole thing we
must eliminate go twos you can call them
go twos if you like you can call them
jumps you can call the branches or
essentially resolving to being the same
thing they and I think most of you from
a a shin your having already or having
seen previous computer file videos will
know that gotas branches jumps etc are
unavoidable at the assembly language
level ok that's the way that machines
actually work you tell them to go to a
different address so what's wrong with
incorporating that idea into
higher-level languages well the argument
was and it's quite right the problem
with the go-to is that programmers never
adequately document alongside why they
are going to a common construct of
course is to have a go-to at the bottom
of a loop to jump back to the top you
check her at the top whether you've
finished the loop or not but in the end
when it's finished you do another go-to
when you jump past it so the next
instruction a good assembler program
will put a little note in there saying
lute finished or something like that so
the argument is well that looping
constructs in a higher-level language
could be replaced by a while and if that
is while is then compiled down into
assembler the gotas will be there but
when you consult back with the
high-level language you know that it was
there because it's a while loop and that
is basically what it comes down to by
using higher level constructs you make
your intentions plain
this enables me to do kill two birds
with one stone some of you are getting
very very worried about unsold Rubik
cubes now a left one here there's some
salt in a particular way that I hope I
can do in real time now without
embarrassing myself this cube is
solvable with two operations called
Gotoh monetarists Gotoh is a very common
Japanese surname and I'm guessing that
the go-to of Gotoh monetarist fame must
have been a Japanese mathematician going
way back to the early 1970s when I first
got this from a set of notes on how to
solve the tube it's all some use man I
always delight in doing it because there
is another go to'
it was a very famous Japanese computer
scientist and so everybody's great
amusement in the 70s or 80s was at a
conference and you have no idea how
stressful it is to have the surname go
to and to be involved in high-level
programming language design and analysis
but Professor why he said people are
always trying to eliminate me is that so
anyway back to the go toes I see that
that one and that one are needing a
twist and you can get things that twist
on their own axis but while even the
rest of the Cuban changed or invariant
as mathematicians like to call it you
can see that there's a sort of threefold
symmetry on these corners you can do one
twist two twists and when you've done
three twists you're bound to be back to
the same place I can see from this one
that it's actually going to need a
couple of these go to Oman or twist
operations to get it to being perfectly
right and I hope I can do them without
goofing up if you ride if you push the
comments on this please don't point out
that that is heavily so optimal yes I
know there's brilliant ways to do it
much more quickly I'm sure so I remember
in group theoretical notation it goes
something like R minus one
they have minus 1 u f d minus 1 f minus
1 Paul - Andre - 1 o u minus 1 that's
progress there's still two things that
are wrong but they now have exactly the
same color and I know from my suboptimal
but at least I couldn't remember its
algorithms
that's another Gotoh mono twist given
they're both the same color and provided
I don't goof up one more will get it
right so here we go - computer
scientists can do limited group Theory
if they try very odd
but it's not enough trespassing on
number five I cannot commit and will not
come into memory these somewhere
something like 90 algorithms I think
you've got to know to be even moderately
good at doing a cube really really
quickly I tend to try and remember about
10 or 12 an except that there's some
optimal but I find them easier to
remember